a very on Broadway like people got
involved in the film - in the put our
first training in Westwood and women
black white yellow green and blue
started talking back and it was
interesting we were cutting the film and
Vin Diesel was cutting his film up there
too so he came by and his his sister is
his producing partner so I showed him
the scene where viola starts telling the
truth or in a big way and he sitting
like where you are and his sister was
sitting over there screens up here and I
just started to see the I'll just watch
this and she starts going in and I start
him mm-hmm and I look she was just like
she left the room that's right
[Music]
building even me I mean there's a
there's a bit it's so real I guess an
honest and people get involved I mean
they people literally sometimes get up
and start talking back to the screen
does not happen when you onstage oh yeah
in the play forget my people with
somebody you know - what I won't give it
I can't give it away but he walks in
with a little one and a woman went oh
let me just go do this but people get
involved and before they know it they're
there in it I mean it's a testament to
how great a writer all this was but also
apparently was very different you were
filming he filmed on-location of
Pittsburgh yeah so it's quite different
from an LA location or a New York
location it was the best because we were
right there where he lives we were right
there where August wasn't lived I mean
we were right there where a lot of
people got involved there was a man that
that lived behind us mr. Greenlee he
couldn't hear well and he would come out
every day and ask if I wanted coffee
during the scene or anytime right we're
shooting now ah
we're shooting now mr. Greenlee you want
some coffee
we're going to go ahead and shoot Han
make them all be gone make him over stop
you know just come out and even get a
chair and sit like he's watching a movie
watching the movie oh he's in the
backyard
yeah I'm going to see it I've seen it
yeah sweet I did not mean to cut you all
don't know that we had a screening in in
Pittsburgh and he came in a suit tie and
just proud I still could hear he had a
guy say no but he was so proud he was
even well he wasn't in the movie but but
he was a part like he made it
[Music]